dude you you more tilted I thought it
was thought I had it straight maybe for
once as if anything about me will ever
be straight ha ha all right for that
ridiculous comment here we go excuse me
while I pour myself some water Chris
how's everybody doing hey there Castillo
how am i I'm tired
as is frequently the case that's kind of
my life is being tired vodka whoo dang
you ain't messing around or are you
suggesting that I'm drinking vodka water
nice Mike yeah I love this mug I got
that two Christmases ago I got this it's
also huge like I take my morning coffee
in this or Italy I used I'm trying to
cut back on the amount of coffee I drink
so I don't take my morning coffee in
this anymore cuz this was like two runs
of the of the coffee maker like the the
single serving coffee makers you had to
run it twice to fill this up would you
drink vodka and straight vodka like I
don't mind vodka as a mixer straight
vodka like chilled maybe but by and
large not really mine my deal o
hufflepuff from Cornwall I like the
t-shirt yes I got I got it in a
different color in the opposite order
because I already had it in gray a with
with this bit on top and that bit on the
bottom but I decided to do this one too
so that I've got variety and I can march
around and be a walking billboard for my
own merch cuz I my shell but I'm a shill
for myself because nobody else will be
do you like T yes I love t I don't like
fruity teas though like the the lemon
zinger and like raspberry but boom no
black tea green tea sometime sure but
like gimme Earl Grey give me English
breakfast
give me like that's that's that to me is
T screwdrivers for the woodsy
screwdrivers that was the kind of thing
that I drank in college so for me that
that takes me back like into a weird
time that not a time I'm sure I I'm sure
I entirely want to revisit Jagermeister
I actually like Jager most people I know
don't like ya you're at all but I
actually do I don't drink it often but I
do like it
favorite coffee blend I actually don't
have one because um I have a favorite
creamer instead because it what does it
Cold Stone Creamery makes a creamer a
sweet cream creamer and that's what I
use and it kind of doesn't matter what
coffee I put it into so I'm not I'm not
exceptionally picky and I and I go
lighter on cream and sugar than I used
to like originally when I first started
drinking coffee but he was I don't and
like again I've softened a little but
like initially certainly I didn't like
coffee what I liked was coffee ice cream
so I would add as much creamy sugar as
it took to make coffee taste as much
like coffee ice cream as I could make it
is there any actual you think shouldn't
ever play the doctor yeah an American
Dad that's it
vodka and tea hmm Earl Grey hot yes of
course hot thanks for fitting the
stereotype of us nerds sassy I do like
girl grade but I actually I like Lady
Grey which is like a slightly milder
version but Earl Grey was kind of a poke
in for tea you know outside of going to
Chinese restaurants and having the the
tea they serve there I love space suits
and
so Pride Month ooh boy combine those get
yourself a rainbow spacesuit Oh speakers
up Oh hot toddies
I made Liz hot toddies this past weekend
because she had a cold but I don't know
folks remember I said that I won my
Oscar pool a few months ago
and I finally got the trophy in I had to
wait to get this because they they put
you know they engrave it for every every
win and so it's like the Stanley Cup I
get to hold on to this for a year until
the next Oscar pool and then whoever
wins that one gets to if they wanted in
their house gets to happen for you
and dang right I wanted at my house I
love this thing this is actually the
second time although last time I won
back in 2014 that was a time so I had I
only got it for six months that time
full year this go yeah I'm very very
happy to have that right there
remind an Irish girl what a hot toddy is
okay so a hot toddy the actual alcohol
you could use with Barry some people use
gin so people use a verb we use bourbon
I did it with rum but it is it is
boiling water and lemon and the the
booze and honey that you melt in the
water and then you know you just gotta
get the portions right and what you end
up with is basically a boozy lemon tea
is what it tastes like
who is Liz's favorite supernatural
character Liz like me doesn't watch
Supernatural so I couldn't tell you
hello from Wales oh gods late there well
early actually I guess it's probably
a.m. by this point nice trophy night
yeah I like it
so my weekend was me realizing I don't
like any of the Austin Powers movies
anymore I don't know how to feel about
that I'm afraid to rewatch the Austin
Powers movies see like here's the thing
I actually never thought the second one
was all that good like that was the one
that blew up huge I really didn't care
for it that much I still like my memory
of the first one was really solid I'm
afraid to put that to the test cuz I
like I'm not sure there's any genre that
inherently ages as badly as comedy does
because and I've actually been um I've
written up a script I don't know when
I'll get around to it I've actually done
a script for a video that would touch on
this and part of the problem with comedy
is the fact that most come any joke is
based off a set of based assumptions
that it is presumed the audience has but
the thing is societally our base
assumptions change as a society and
about people about certain kinds of
people so the reason jokes aged so badly
is because the base assumptions about
what is acceptable as a target for a
joke or what is acceptable as the
groundwork that you build a joke on that
stuff all shifts just naturally over
time and then but the joke is frozen in
time as whatever it was it's so funny
like all these all these things about
Austin Powers they're getting flagged
for potential bad language because of
the just because of things like Fat
Bastard and and Austin [ __ ] and we'll
see if my saying them out loud now gets
this thing to monetize we'll see
surprise visit of your daughter in last
week's video may my weeks so cutie here
your combo I honestly thought I'd cut
that out
oh this is this is why I need to stop
editing what I'm tired because this is
what like I I make a very strong point
to not shoot when I'm tired because I
don't know if anyone else can tell but
there are times that I look at myself
I'm like oh god I look like we're about
to pass out um but what I we do is
shoot when I was awake but I would edit
late into the night I got stopped
editing tired that said people seem to
really dig the heck out of that peeing
left in there so I'm glad people got a
kick out of it um more often than not I
leave mistakes in because it's pretty
rare that they're so egregious that it
like ruins the entire video so that's
far from the only video where I've left
a mistake in by and large though I just
leave them which video it was earlier
this week Oh God which one was it
it was the God why can't I remember my
own stuff hang on I bet you somebody's
already answered it it was I think it
was the Hitchhiker's Guide video or
maybe or was it that wasn't the one
about the Judoon I can't remember now
somebody else will say oh it was the
Hitchhiker's video yes that that was the
one I got audible reason recently I used
my credits to get and pre-order the
doctor who lost TV stories collection
I'm scared for the celestial toymaker
like Oh long-term project I really want
to get an audio version of my book put
together but uh I need to hire a
professional sound engineer
it's a like to pull that together worth
of dang and I can't afford it so
ravenclaw from California well hi to you
too Tracy I was a decent hour where you
are Irish Breakfast is delicious yes I
agree with that one a lot of Eddie
Murphy stand-up is unwatchable to me now
yeah yeah that yeah that's that's kind
of a good go-to example but actually I
think that's why like some of my
favorite comedian ball time is George
Carlin I think a lot of his earlier
stuff like from the 60s and 70s actually
holds up better than his stuff from like
the nineties onward which is actually
discovered him so I'm more nostalgic for
it but and that's not to say that the
stuff he didn't eyes was actually worse
but the older stuff aged better because
the older stuff he did on more broad
topics so like talking about the nature
of language talking about you know the
nature of religious and superstitious
beliefs these are broad topics whereas
his later stuff he would talk very
specifically about what was going on
right now in political arenas and it was
good for as long as it stayed topical
but being topical means it ages faster
which comedy has a just age the best so
oh boy Eddie is ARDS age is pretty well
um so far because he'll have pop-culture
references but he tends to stick to
stuff that has stood the test of time
so his age is pretty well some are right
yeah some of Robin Williams stuff has
aged poorly but like that is a pop
culture thing but he like throws in so
many pop-culture references and actually
like unpopular opinion Alejandra's
performance in Aladdin doesn't hold up
that well because of how dated some of
those references are and honestly some
of them I didn't even get at the time
some of them I still don't so you know
anything that reference the attention on
age well and like um also not
necessarily a popular opinion but let's
go with with unpleasant one it's Bill
Cosby himself if you can still bring
yourself to look at the man and I can't
I had my copy of that and I got rid of
it but that has aged really well because
it's about parenting and it's about
family relationships and it's about the
kind of dynamics that haven't changed
massively from decade over decade or
even if they have you can still relate
to what he's talking about so I really
hate that I have to cite that as like an
example of a comedy set that has aged
amazingly well but I can't watch it
anymore so there you go
lost something here AG dang it I can get
it back are you gonna see Rocket Man
when it comes out this week I saw it
already it's a beautiful musical biopic
that I highly recommend actually yes Liz
is super pumped for that so yes we are
we are making an effort to see that as
soon as we can from when it comes out
that does not mean I'll be making a
video on it I don't promise that if it
blows me away I might but otherwise like
it's just kind of outside the wheelhouse
of this channel um are you a fan of the
Bands Supertramp I know the name I don't
know if I know any of their songs though
like I probably do but Bill Hicks ah
some ability stuff on religion has aged
pretty well Bill Hicks is political
stuff has aged okay better than you'd
think
his specific reference is naming
specific political figures that hasn't
aged great obviously those people aren't
in power anymore but from the
perspective of he skewering a certain
political perspective and just naming
some people who are who hold that one it
holds up all right buildings buildings
does okay um I've seen it I agree I just
want to see what counsel them geeks
things um well I mean we'll see if if
nothing else
after seeing Rocket Man I'll definitely
talk about it on the livestream so
there's that age shockingly well Andy
Griffith Show and Gilligan's Island and
not a big fan of either one but honestly
I could believe that and actually like I
feel like like wordplay age as well I
mean that's why Shakespeare comedies are
still good Death Star Cantina is still
my favorite Eddie his heart bit that
that is that is a good bit and I saw
Eddie perform in Burlington a couple
years ago and he kind of revived that
bit like he didn't do it again but he
did it called
to it bringing back mr. Stevens the head
of catering oh god I love that I love
that man too dad ah it's your favorite
kind of titles for Doctor Who I like
titles that are creepy and mysterious
and give viewers questions before
watching an example of this is it takes
you away um I really thought about it
before what I will say is unless the
unless they're revealed like within the
first five minutes I don't like the name
of the villain being put in the title um
you know like uh whatever of the Daleks
I'll kind of roll with but like even
that honestly sometimes like Daleks in
Manhattan should not have had Daleks in
the title because for how long it is
before they actually show up and the way
that they had exited the show at the end
of series two it should have been much
more surprising when they showed up
again but instead it's in the friggin
title so yeah I think the exception is
somewhat Romilly was roles but I'm n I'm
heavily biased as I look up to him at
his work well it's not that his roles
have aged when I say comedy is aged like
mostly I'm talking about jokes um that
tend to age poorly like comedy styles
can hold up well comedic performances
can hold up well but like specific jokes
setup punchline that that's the kind of
stuff that tends to age not very well
all things considered did you find time
to watch the twilight zone reboot
I have not if I'm very lucky
um Liz alerted me that season four of
legends of tomorrow is now on Netflix so
I can get started on that if I can find
the time I'm oh yeah there's a lot of
stuff I'm working I'm still working on
the book player games I'm working on
a Netflix series that I got commissioned
to do I'm editing a monster of a video
that is turning in excuse me but it's
turning into a lot more work than I
expected it to so boy you know a lot of
a lot of stuff to try and find time to
do things then and we got the
announcement for Jessica Jones that's
coming out in what three weeks haha
gotta fit that in now too good and and
black mirror we got three more black
mirrors coming out hey like I love what
I do but man sometimes this stuff piles
up
have you watched orange is the new black
I watched the first two seasons and
stopped because season one I was mixed
on season two I liked and then
everything I heard about what went on
after that I'm like I'm just gonna
pretend it ended its season two thank
you very much yeah I finally got some
pronoun pins congratulations Jasper very
cool airplane is a great comedy that
still works well it actually
surprisingly it does but it's because
like as much as it's a spoof it's
playing with broad tropes as opposed to
parroting specific films which it
actually does do as well but most of the
jokes are about generally the broader
the target of a joke is the better in
ages the more specific it is the less
likely it's gonna age well unless the
something is not gonna change like like
language changes so slowly that word
play usually ages pretty well I quit
after season five I'm assuming you mean
on orange is the new black
do you like Umbrella Academy I did I
didn't I wasn't in love with it um but
no I liked it pretty well I want to see
another season finally finished Cowboy
Bebop except for the movie need to catch
up on ducktales oh god yeah I need to
catch up on ducktales - so yeah yeah the
the video that that is driving me crazy
the editing of is a video on Cal
bebop and it's it's just it is a lot of
work yeah
then this is what I get for getting more
ambitious and wanting to include clips
and have it flow well and do stuff like
that like I can wrap my head around it
but man it's it's a slog of a process
farewell
Marvel Netflix may we see you in better
times I just hope it goes out well I did
not like second season of Jessica Jones
Robert Pattinson is Batman thoughts good
work I mean that's that's kind of all I
got
do you like Bojack horseman I've never
watched it
I've heard great things about it but
I've also heard it's monstrously
depressing and AH I don't think I'm up
for monstrously depressing not in an
extended way like black mare I can do
because as depressing is black mare can
be it's an hour and I can take a break
before I watch more it's not hour upon
hour upon hour of me seeing the same
depressing things happening to these
gerd like I'm not I'm not up for it
what's up guys just joined in hi
Jonathan uh said it before but I love
David Tennant as Scrooge McDuck yeah he
slipped into that part really well have
you seen that flicks is a series of
unfortunate events I did about three
episodes of that I didn't dislike it I
just didn't like it enough to keep
watching it over other stuff are you
excited for Good Omens yes
oh man that's another one coming out
soon that I'm gonna have to so much time
I have to find hey have you seen killing
Eve that one I have not
Monty Python's definitely gonna last
forever absurdism age is pretty well
because it's so weird even at the time
it comes out it just stays weird
Jon Hamm is the saint yeah in Good Omens
that'll be interesting frankly I wish
everyone would stop writing about Robert
Pattinson as Batman at this point all
right I mean are they what like I'm not
even paying attention to the
conversation like I bowed out right at
the beginning because initially when
that story broke it wasn't confirmed and
so I and officially I still don't think
it is actually but like it hasn't been
shot down so even if it isn't what's
gonna happen at the very least as close
to happening so it's it more than likely
but I've just stayed out of the
conversation are people bitching about
it why because it's apply light like the
Twilight was the job his agent told him
was good for him and his agent was right
for the record look at other stuff he's
done not that I think he's an amazing
stellar actor but like his resume is not
vastly dissimilar from bales prior to
taking a Batman the only difference is
he was like imagine if Newsies had
resulted in three sequels and then you
know that's basically what Robert
Pattinson is dealing with with with
Twilight hanging around his neck so I
mean I'm not going like he'll be great I
have no idea but I have no reason to
think he's gonna be bad either petitions
haven't made all petitions I pay zero
attention to fan petitions at this point
it's become a joke I see the word fan
petitions that my brain just shuts off I
just I can't anymore ah Godzilla king of
the top Lex ha ha ha he was pretty good
with David Cronenberg I couldn't get
into that one that they did together
although Cronenberg is one of those odd
directors for me to where like I
appreciate his stuff and I'll watch it
once and then I'll never want to watch
it again Robert always beefs Cedric
Diggory in my heart as for many people
I'm sure are you more excited for Doctor
Who series 12 or the good play series
for both of both Park Illinois with
excitement can't wait I don't know I
don't measure my
Siteman I'm not I don't know I'm not one
to compare and contrast what am i more
excited for no I'd like Mike Symons for
very different reasons I'm excited for
the good place because it hasn't let me
down yet and I want to see what's next
I'm excited for Doctor Who series 12
because I want to see how it refines and
improve so there you go
petition to stop petitions oh my god if
that doesn't exist on change.org it
needs to a petition to dismantle
internet petition websites Pattinson
hated doing Twilight I heard oh yeah oh
yeah yeah like watch an interview with
him talking about that one time or
listen to the commentary tracks like I
haven't done the whole things with us
but like I've heard snippets it's very
clear that he had no interest in this
and he did it for it for the boost to
his career it was a career move for him
that's all it was and I mean that's all
it was for for Christmas Stewart as well
cuz like she like she was a little bit
of somebody but but then there's folks
like Taylor Lautner who you could tell
was really trying because like he wasn't
anybody before before that started
current favorite doctor Capaldi number
12
ghosts and rogue on a unique adventure
series let's reboot as lab geeks with
outside shots and natural light ah no
sir you will not find me in son I
finally got around to watching the caves
of Androzani yesterday it was glories
I'm overdue to rewatch that I mean I
like it but I haven't seen it for ages
the only petition I allowed to be a
thing as for class to get a second
season most underrated show ever I saw
the same class so I I don't have an
opinion on that Michael Sheen was the
only good thing about the Twilight
movies he was a delight I actually I
kind of loved the last Twilight movie
because
is such a uniquely bloggers form of bad
like it's insane like that's the that's
the thing the Twilight movies prior to I
would say the last two definitely the
you know the last one
their main sin was being boring they
were dull so little happened but that
last one is nuts it's insane like
honestly if you've never seen any of the
Twilight movies just watch the last one
get friends get drinks if you're over
two if you're of age and just lap your
asses off it's kind of amazing would you
be interested in a Doctor Who
Halloween's special I mean I'd be
curious
the thing is though Doctor Who is
capable of being scary in an average
everyday episode so I'm not entirely
sure how that would differ from standard
operating procedure or you know you you
wouldn't need um you wouldn't need an
excuse to go scary you know I don't know
recently watch your Doctor Who villains
to not come back do you think the Vashta
Nerada could return but only briefly and
a specialist something like that I mean
no no cuz I figured there's only one of
two things to do with the Bastian Narada
either the exact thing that they already
did um or I guess one of three things
these I think they already did
completely change the way they operate
the way that they did with the Angels
which then minimizes what they were or
have them appear like in a very
conciliatory minor fashion like there's
like a villainous set up a maze and
there's a room with Vashta Nerada and
like it just as a nod but then that's
also minimizing good they also did that
with the weeping angels to like just
leave them alone
leave them alone they're perfect for the
story that they're in leave them there
Doctor Who Halloween special is called
watered waters of Mars
FairPoint do you have thoughts on julia
Raynham your favorite bad movies
I don't cuz I'm not even sure I'll have
a top ten because like that what what I
just went through with that last
Twilight movie that's a rarity for me it
is really rare for me to get enjoyment
out of a bad movie I usually just get
find them bad by and large I don't I
just don't I just don't do the so bad
it's good thing as a rule so like I did
I think I'd have a hard time even
thinking of ten come out the Capaldi
banged his head on the TARDIS and Jodie
was a coma I also love that Chinese
doctors are very kind like Capaldi said
to be in his lecture to her in the
regeneration yeah I mean I like I get
Jodi's approach I get Jodie Whitaker's
approach to to playing the doctor I just
I feel like the problem right now is the
writing like we haven't had proper
emphasis on her so yeah would you do a
list of disappointing movies then well I
mean I kind of do every year that I do
my top ten I have dishonorable mentions
towards the tail-end and I'll mention
the worst movie I saw that year and the
most disappointing movie I saw that year
so are you excited for Steven Moffat
Stevie series adaptation of the Time
Traveler's Wife
no because the book is great and doesn't
need to be a show and Steven Moffat has
better uses of his time because he
effectively already did the Time
Traveler's Wife with River Song he's
already done love story out of order
chronologically like that I hadn't heard
this if he's actually doing that that
sounds like slumming it to me hey yeah
yeah wasn't he working on a Dracula
thing I don't know look I love the book
the Time Traveler's Wife but leave it
alone again like
things adapt well some things don't
or they'll just adapt like laterally
it'll be no better than the original
source already was wait you like killer
krons from outer space or any other
benign 80's 90's movies not really
there's just not really my bag River
with 13
I would like river to see Whitaker and
and say hello sweetie
but ultimately no I think rivers story
was done and I think they need to let it
be done
as he spent oh okay so black Glover why
shouldn't an American play the doctor
huh number of reasons one just because
I'm a stubborn jackass and I just don't
think it should happen I just don't
think I think is too quintessentially
British a show
I mean honestly we dodged a massive
bullet given that the TV movie that had
McGann in it was financed then shot in
America we were really lucky they didn't
cast an American and I don't ever want
to go down that road again
I don't I don't want Doctor Who to be
Americanized not in terms of its
approach not in terms of its shooting
style not in terms of its mentality and
not in terms of the actor I just don't
want it I
I love how unabashedly British the show
is and I never want to lose that and
don't tell me that an American can do a
British accent just get a British actor
from anywhere any of those Islands any
one of them have a Welsh doctor fine not
an American no what advice do you have
for gender-fluid people who aren't out
yet but other people in their life won't
be you say won't be upsetting do you
mean won't be understanding or won't be
upset I'm like I'm not entirely sure
what you meant to say there so clarify
and I'll come back to you Captain Jack
returning isn't confirmed not so far as
I know and if it is I don't want to know
I would like to be surprised by
something every now and then well what
would you think of Big Finish writers
writing for TV Doctor Who would that
work I mean it could and they even did
it to some extent because they had the
guy who wrote da like a rigidly it was
jubilee human nature was a novel that
wasn't they finished but that was also
done like it can't happen but like
people have said they want the Big
Finish people to take over Doctor Who I
don't it's not because I don't think
they do Welles like they do what they do
very well and also running a TV show is
not the same as
audio adventures it's a fundamentally
different skill and whether or not you
feel like the current team is any good
at it you don't go that far off the
reservation to try and write the ship
you know if your plumber stinks you
don't suddenly hire a carpenter to do
your plumbing it's a different skill set
would you like Martha and Mickey to
return at this point I'm not sure I'd
really care like I'm I'm not really that
big on too many of the the characters
from previous eras of modern who coming
back I I don't want the show to become
overly navel-gazing or too overly
obsessed with its own history because
then things just become circular and it
makes the universe feel small that like
instead of the doctor encountering new
people they just keep running into the
same people over and over again I just
don't like that as a thing
I meant won't be accepting okay um well
okay so in terms of coming out there's
no there's no easy way there's no set
way to quote-unquote do it there's no
way to really do it right and if you
know that the people or if you're fairly
certain that the people in your life are
not going to be accepting or
understanding or supportive then kind of
all you can do is just be blunt I mean
the one thing I'd say is have a be
careful because I don't know your
situation so like I'm always very
cautious for folks who are still living
at home usually that's when it comes to
teenagers if if you are still in some
way dependent on the people you believe
won't support you be very very careful
because there is a reason that that
trans youth make up a disproportionate
percentage of the homeless population
and it's because they get thrown out of
their homes so if you are dependent on
people who will not accept you I hate to
recommend anybody in the closet that
just know know that you have somewhere
to go whether it's a friend whether it's
a relative whether it's shelter
somewhere before you you try and come
out but if if that's not your situation
and they just don't know yet but you
want to not be hiding it from them all
you can do is tell them plainly and move
forward as best you can like I've been
very fortunate I have yet to have to
come out to anyone who wasn't accepting
I thought to say every single person
I've ever met in my life is totally cool
with it but the people who have mattered
to me what they thought have all been
supportive and I am insanely fortunate
for that and I know that not everyone's
is lucky most aren't
I saw in free m'as Instagram that she
ran into Tom Ellis at a common SLC
Martha and Tom Milligan reunion
oh it's cool I prefer my modern classic
who drags a lot and awesome and often as
quite poor actors and awkward jokes um
like you need to be able to get into the
to the headspace of the era to enjoy a
classic ooh and you need to be able to
overlook some pretty wonky production
design sometimes but in terms of overall
writing mentalities there's a lot to
like abut at least for me about classic
who but there's some pretty sizeable and
very visible hurdles that you have to
overcome sometimes just remember to your
heel story you told impossible not to my
face why do people have why do people
have to be mean to people because of
something as simple as gender or race or
religion let others live the way they
want why can't everyone just be a you do
you person look that'd be nice and then
the thing is there's plenty of people
out there who think they are that but
when actually confronted with somebody
that is outside of their group whatever
it is they can still get weird so like I
live in Vermont and Vermont is a very
tolerant state in a lot of ways it's
actually the top-rated state as far as
you know by by a number of metrics as
far as acceptance of lgbtq+ populace but
Vermont doesn't have a great track
record on race and a fair amount of that
has to do with the fact that there is
Vermont's a really white state I don't
know what the percentage is now but it's
like 90% white at minimum probably I
wouldn't be surprised if it is if it is
90
five and plenty of Vermonters think that
they are as tolerant about races they
are about other things but because they
don't have people who aren't white that
they're confronting day to day they
don't have anyone to kind of force them
to challenge their ideas and their
preconceptions I don't mean like get in
their face and say Church you're
privileged I just mean like when you
have to actually exist with somebody you
come to understand them better and you
come to understand them more importantly
on their own terms as opposed to the
terms that you project onto them and
that's why diversity is so important
because when you're in a in a
monochromatic and and isolated in a
unified group your understanding of
anyone who isn't part of that group just
it erodes or it never builds in the
first place so as wonderful as you know
the whole idea of everyone should be
live and let live which yeah I mean to
an extent there's some things I like nah
not okay but you know that's that that's
it's the obvious red line crosses that I
don't even feel like getting into but
yeah to hell with Nazis that's my point
but any anyways you it's we all have
prejudices that we don't realize we have
until we actually are forced to confront
them in some way shape or form and some
people when that happens can't deal with
it and it's not fun I've been lucky my
mom has recognized that I've been deaf
me for a long time originally she
thought I was aced
and is supportive I have to explain to
others what both are though that yeah I
can't that is kind of one of the things
is that anyone falling in the lgbtq+
spectrum who falls under the plus so you
know your your demisexuals your asexuals
your non binaries you know and anyone
who who is outside lesbian gay bisexual
trans and I get queers kind of a blanket
term it can mean a lot of things
depending on who's using it but like
those those four
not everyone approves but everyone gets
what it is you don't have to define
those but you try to explain to somebody
that you are gender fluid or that you're
a gender or asexual or demisexual like
you have to define your terms cuz a lot
of people aren't even gonna know what
that you're talking about all true I'm
still a work in progress we're all works
in progress the progress never never
stops I did my final presentation today
on diverse eree diversity and how to
embrace it oh that's lovely
to hell with Nazis Nathanael 2019 can I
get that on a shirt Wow that'll be the
next merch I put together is that to
hell with Nazi shirt too Bad's were
humans humans really do suck yeah humans
are just kind of yeah I didn't come out
as gay until I was 25
you know God in Lousiana mind you most
of being cold but I got some people who
don't mind it at all given my
understanding of sort of that part of
the country because I'm I've never
really been down there that sounds like
you got about as good as you're gonna
get as far as reaction goes how many
more letters will be officially added
before we need something shorter before
we need something shorter to call the
LGBT instead of see that the reason I
use lgbtq+ is it's an acknowledgment
that there's a bunch more because if I
try and do all the letters which last
time I checked and there might be more
last time I checked the full thing was
LGBTQIA pique um and like I said that
was like a couple years ago but I go
with lgbtq+ cuz the plus is like my
acknowledgement that like I know there's
more and just please take it as my
acceptance of everyone involved my
priorities when watching a Doctor Who
story is that it's creepy or at least
fun those are both good things for
Doctor Who to be if it can be both hey
never visit Louisiana not even New
Orleans it's human miserable racist and
we and we have David Duke yeah like I
there's a burlesque performance that I
follow who's from Louisiana who like I
really like like I need to see if she
ever does a festival away from Louisiana
I guess cuz I'd love to meet her in
person one of these days but couldn't
work out what I was decided to go queer
and save the hassle where's a good
blanket term I find some people use it
more specifically shirt idea and the
failing to foreground face palming
varies Doctor Who monsters in the
background and then text above the image
oh wait it's aliens I hadn't thought of
that one specifically I have been
conceptual conceptualizing possibilities
for an oh wait it's aliens shirt so like
it's on my list to try and figure out
Gentleman Jack is a great series I've
heard a few people mention it I haven't
seen that one it's on HBO though I
think's and I I dropped HBO soon as Game
of Thrones ended so there you go
I like the GRS and macron em gender
romance sexual minorities haha thank you
for those that use q+ if used in the
lgbtq+ acronym week hue plus types get
ignored enough already
GRS em I'm not sure I had heard that one
before or if I had it's been a while and
forgotten about it like if that one
became more popular in use I'd totally
be on board for that that I mean that is
one of those cases where you know we can
say we'd like to be called this but if
it doesn't get adopted widely you know
what was the use but if that never gets
picked up I'd be on board for that
gotta go for a minute oh well hurry back
Ari
I love when the doctor is fascinated
with things they find it's my favorite
type of scene I like when the doctor
gets excited cuz they don't know
something I I am always down for that
what do you think of King bran like most
of season eight of Game of Thrones
totally solid idea if the execution and
a rocky journey getting there like at
this point I I think what happened the
game of Thrones is incredibly obvious to
look at it they once they outpaced the
books and they didn't have the rich
layered detailed material to work for
many more what happened was that all
they had was basically the cliff notes
they had George RR Martin's outline of
what was going to happen in where
characters were gonna end up but without
the full breadth of how they got there
as a resource anymore cuz they didn't
have full books to go by the last couple
seasons just plays like cliff notes and
then this and then this and then this
and you're like but the journey where's
the journey so would you ever like
Doctor Who to crossover with another
show no no no I wouldn't like I I might
I'm debating doing a video exploring the
idea of whether or not Doctor Who in
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy take
place in the same universe cuz I've got
evidence for and against um so you know
III don't mind like little nods to to
Doctor Who or Doctor Who doing not
something else like implying that
something else is going but like proper
crossovers meeting other characters or
other case meaning the doctor no no I
don't think so where we where I live we
use the umbrella term diverse people
that works anime fills the void with
cat-eared boys now
haha there are a lot of Cattier people
in in anime what about a non-canon w
crossover i mean if they wanted to do
like i mean if they want to do something
like dimensions in time but have it not
be painful like as a one-off in a goof
sure fine
just don't do it cannon don't do it in
show the Tenth Doctor is literally Ford
Prefect if he was a big spearing the emo
yet I can't remember who was who coming
and somebody on the Hitchhiker's videos
that the Ford Prefect was like the
doctor if he was bad at his job gotta
love tens good old JK uh-huh
that was a bit I was a bit I mean like I
know
Rowling's not like been involved with
doctor but that that felt that felt
preemptive like this especially given
that it was like it was done before the
last book could come out now the last
Harry Potter books fine it's you know it
wasn't like it completely wrecked it but
like boy that that could have gone that
could have got a real bad if if it had
stunk
the bigger question of cat-eared boys
and animes which ones are official and
which ones are fan art in anime all fan
art is eventually made canon even the
hentai fan art
oddly enough 10 is less dangerous than
Ford Prefect is like hoardin oh man Ford
Prefect
it will be fun going out with drinking
with him until he started a bar fight
and left you with the tab because he
would nothing wrong with cat-eared boys
I don't know why I love the Kaffir boys
which anime are good I depends on what
you like I mean you need to realize
enemy is not a genre anime is an artform
so there's a wide range of anime there's
romance and there's horror and there's
sci-fi in this fantasy and there's adult
family drama like whatever
genres you like another entertainment
you can find an equivalent in anime and
back for a few minutes before bed well
welcome back and when you go to bed I
hope you sleep well case I miss you
bowing out it's on deadline look for
film Miller and Phil Lord and Chris
Miller deal with Sony what I'm not gonna
look it up now somebody tell me what
happened and the comic Star Trek in
Doctor Who crossed over yeah Star Trek
is also crossed on board with x-men in
the comics come on
something I recently remembered you
might find interesting seeing as it's
both inside and outside your immediate
wheelhouses in Star Wars Knights the Old
Republic if you play as a female can
enter into a homo romantic relationship
with Juhani one of your female
companions who is who I believe
canonically is the first lesbian in Star
Wars oh that is cool
I do find it interesting that like I'm
presuming based off what you're saying
that there isn't an option for a male
homosexual pairing only a female
homosexual pairing which the presumed
teenage male audience of a videogame
would think is hot so I mean there's my
cynicism slow
back in because it does cuz I'm I'm I'm
kind of a cynical prick when you get
right down to it are you ever gonna give
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure try I don't
know maybe someday at the risk of
annoying you hold on I lost it now what
annoys me is when the chat Scrolls past
me
should they do a new Hitchhiker's Guide
TV series incorporating all the books I
honestly don't think so
and it has to do with why why I like the
novels as the best which is that for me
what makes Hitchhiker's Guide truly
special is Adams is narrative voice and
narrative voice doesn't carry over into
visual medium it just doesn't you lose
it and yes you can still have the
dialogue that the character saying you
can even still have guide entries
narrated by somebody I mean Stephen Fry
did them well in the movie but the way
that he describes me the words he uses
to describe things that gets lost and
and for me at least that is such a big
part of what I love about those books
that now I don't really want to see it
adapt into a visual medium
I grew up watching reruns of 50s and 70s
TV and I've seen lots of 90s classic who
has similar production values to a
standard sitcom drama of the era why
does everyone seem to think it looks
crap I think largely because most others
stuff from that era isn't viewed anymore
of it because Doctor Who is still going
people from now are going back and
looking at it and they don't if they
don't have the breadth of experience of
other video of other TV of the time then
they don't have a comparison and they
just go oh god that looks like garbage
but let's be honest there were some
times that doctor who looked by garbage
like sometimes it just did not always
but sometimes even by the standards of
the era
sometimes it was bad
love the shirt thank you it's for sale
on my merch store I think the last
anyway I saw was one punch man I did two
episodes of that and it just it just
didn't help me I agree on the narrative
voice I got hung up on how you would do
the guy on TV Peter Jones did it so well
on the on the radio yeah like the Guide
sections you could do but at least it's
it still wouldn't be enough throws in
the obligatory it was a radio show first
comment about chick hitchhiker I know
that but the novels are still better
being the first version of something is
always the best version it often is but
not always when I was a kid I thought
Daleks were just the monsters that
appeared in a show my dad like how old
were you and you found out about Dalek
um the first time I remember noticing a
Dalek was in a red dwarf sort of joke
promotional thing it was like an A to Z
thing and like for the DS they had
Daleks talking about Red Dwarf and like
one of them expressed kind of liking and
the other one was like you showed
enjoyment that is not like a doll like
any blows him away and I didn't like
them because like God that voice is
really annoying I really needed to see
them in context the Daleks outside the
context of Doctor Who like whenever the
Dalek show up is like a joke in
something else and like it doesn't work
at least I don't think it does maybe I'm
nuts I actually discovered the dollies
in the mr. bean Christmas episode okay
yeah what are your thoughts on Scott
Pilgrim the books I haven't read the
books I my opinion of the movie has gone
down with time and so I haven't felt the
desire to go and read the books
even before I know exactly what a Dalek
was I else I would also put my face near
a fan and say exterminating a weird
voice they're just so iconic even non
fans know them I mean I think they're a
little bit more ingrained in British pop
culture than American but yeah certainly
in Lego Batman
oh yeah God the well the doll like show
up in Lego Batman but then just referred
to as British robots Scott Pilgrim book
is actually better than the movie I mean
like I'm prepared to believe that but
it's just I don't know the the
relationship dynamic alright look I'm
just gonna ask the spoiler question
alright Castille f at the end do Ramona
and Scott end up together
that's my only question I have no place
to go if my mom were to throw me out I
have a very very few in real life
friends and I don't know what shelter I
go to I live in a rural area that
doesn't have a bus service then
unfortunately Karasu that my
recommendation is don't come out you put
yourself in too much danger by doing
that and I I do
it breaks my heart to have to tell you
that to advise anybody to do that but
you need to be safe and if it's not safe
for you to come out then you shouldn't
and I hate that yeah they do okay so if
it ends with Scott and Ramona getting
together I don't care I don't want it
because what the ending of that should
be is both of them realize they are too
freeing damages individuals and they
both need to learn how to be single for
a while
any ending that is the two of them
getting together I don't want I don't
want it I don't care like I I need more
relationship movies that end with the
parties breaking up and it's not a
tragedy it's like oh no I should be
single for a bit because there's so many
people in my life I'm like could you
just learn how to be good with yourself
but they jump from relationship to
relationship and I'm not strictly
blaming pop culture for that but pop
culture doesn't help Scott Ramona have
much better chemistry in the books it's
not the chemistry that I questioned it's
the very nature of who they are as
people
Nathaniel you're so compassionate I it's
it's funny that I don't usually think of
myself as compassionate I think probably
just because despite my ego my own
opinion of myself is probably not as is
not as glowing as maybe I come across
especially if I stop and think I mean
part of it haha let's get introspective
for a second right here ought to have
the tail end so like
part of the reason that I stay as busy
as I do and that I'm you know doing four
videos a week and I was doing a video a
day for a while and that I do
performance in burlesque and and I write
and I do all this stuff is that if I
slow down and I get introspective I it's
better than it used to be but certainly
historically I haven't loved what I've
seen and I'm better than I used to be
with that I think a lot of it just
having to do with with having evolved
enough and kind of at least but the time
being broken some of my worst habits but
you know you uh you move forward however
you need to and I have I try to be self
aware I try and have enough
introspection like to have an
understanding of who I am but like deep
soul-searching scares me because when
I'm engaged in it previously it hasn't
hasn't always left me in a good space
and not I mean like not because of any
of this not because of gender fluidity
just because of past actions bad habits
selfishness
but I try and get better at accepting
compliments like that like somebody
calls me compassionate because my ah my
instinct is go no not really and I I
don't know maybe maybe I'm better than I
give myself credit for Wow
okay funny one I like when I let my
guard down a little bit sometimes but
you care you know the feeling and you
can help someone figure this out I'm I I
always hope that I can help I am not so
arrogant as to assume that I do but I'll
I'll keep doing things that I hope will
help and every now and then I hear that
they did that that counts for a lot
when it happens would you want to live
in the culture I'm not sure I would like
because I think like most post-scarcity
sci-fi cultures it runs the risk of just
being boring but then again I'm not done
with the book so when I finish it maybe
my opinion will change but for how far
in it I am I like hmm I wouldn't want to
live there what is going on I don't even
know I don't know anymore
uh you seem very kind and empathetic
thank you
did oh did he she go through a breakup
no no I didn't go through a breakup
I just had an introspective moment live
on camera it's laughing I didn't go
through a breakup I'm good haha
liz is amazing I'm Z this weekend
hopefully we're gonna go see Rocket Man
so no late relationship my relationship
is like one part of my life that like I
have no fears about right now which is
nice so don't don't worry about that you
help me consider coming out it hasn't
happened yet though hey don't when
you're ready you'll get there you do
help quite a lot actually is one of my
favorite channels because it's the safe
space from what you do you really are
own pathetic and so sweet oh thank you
make certain way I feel it I have body
dysphoria myself I hate my body my
failures feel the ugliest person in the
world I always wish I could have the
money to get surgeries and time to get
to the gym that the gym I do feel you
want I don't think I'll ever have
surgeries like even if n like I still I
still maintain that I'm never gonna do a
full transition to like full time life
as a woman but even if theoretically
let's just go completely antithetical
even if I did I don't see myself ever
getting surgery as part of that I don't
see myself ever getting actual sexual
reassignment surgery I don't see myself
getting face you know facial
feminization surgery I just don't see
that like the idea of surgical
alteration of my body kind of freaks me
out a little bit I've only had one
surgery in my life that was my vasectomy
I like to avoid having others if I can
help it really to me that's like saying
you don't want to be happy or safe I
mean I get what you're saying but the
thing is I I look at who I and and like
for people for reference like he's
asking me the question you asked about
the culture which is in the book that
I'm working on reading right now player
of games by Iain M banks
so the whole society this takes place in
the culture it's kind of it's a bit
utopia esque
but like the thing is to the degree that
I am comfortable with who I am and that
I actually continue to feel better about
me over time because as I said like I'm
in a better place about me than I have
been historically and I wouldn't be in
the place where I am now with myself
without everything that's gone on up to
this point good and bad so I can't help
but feel that plunking down plunking me
down into a youto be a society that
isn't gonna challenge me inherently and
it's just a safe space this is not
knocking I'm not like knocking safe
spaces that's not what I mean I'm
talking about a fictional utopia here
plugging me down in a space like that is
just gonna I'm not gonna need to evolve
and I don't like that idea for myself
you know I'm still working on the book
I'm not saying it will make a bad story
or bad narrative I'm just ahead we've
gone all hypothetical here I like this
channel because so much more than Doctor
Who in pop culture if you weren't a
transition Folio would you use Vera's
your official name would you keep that
as your blue last name I mean I I would
probably go buy beer cuz at this point
like that is very very firmly my
feminine name that's how I think of it
full-time as a woman is boring even as a
syst female the woman 24/7 will never I
have ASD which sucks because humans want
social time but how much my brain but
but like how my brain is wired it's
weird because I don't have the natural
ability to do the social bit without
messing up like I I have a weird balance
when it comes to the introvert extrovert
dynamic and I and I I do need to wrap it
up soon but so the thing for me is I
need I need some firm thing for me to
hold on to so I need some familiar
element to stabilize me to bring out the
extrovert youth you throw me in a
totally new situation and I will clam up
like nobody's business
like I get stressed out the first time I
go to any location I've never been
before and not just because I suck at
directions cuz I do but like there's so
much my history is like showing up to
some place I've never been before and
something is weird about it and like I
have the wrong address or like I'm there
at the wrong time and nobody's there yet
or I'm there late and everybody's left
or like there's I I know the building
went out the apartment number I ring the
wrong apartment like I I get anxiety
about that kind of stuff all the friggin
time so I I need to either know the
place or the people if I don't know
either one is just like hey come hang
out and like I don't really know anybody
and it's some place I've never been
before like not fun for me not not a
good time
start to watch Game of Thrones now I'm
on season 3 uh enjoy the wedding
basically all the culture novels revolve
around people leaving it to interact
with more primitive societies societies
where conflict can still exist well I
mean like I said once I finish it you'll
you'll get my full thoughts on it yes
thank you I need that stabilizer just
have a security blanket and every time I
try to break out it feels like a mess or
others ignore me or I just kind of fade
away Oh God
I feel yeah like I do okay as long as I
can have that once at least one
stabilizing thing so like I'll be okay
going to a situate a place I haven't
been before with a lot of people I
haven't met before if say I go with Liz
because
no she's not gonna abandon me and like
if I get comfortable enough to break off
she'll also let me do that but you know
a lot of us here have anxiety I
certainly do I think I mean I think some
degree things I he's just pretty normal
it's just pretty human you struggle with
directions not trying to diagnose you
but do you think you may be a bit just
black sick
I don't know dyspraxia and it's what
what I suck at specifically is my sense
of distance is for crap
and so like in the days before reliable
GPS on say your phone so back when I had
to like print out directions on MapQuest
in order to get anywhere I would have to
remember to use like the the trip
odometer on my car to record you know
cuz it's like three point four miles
down the road take this turn because you
need to realize living in Vermont a lot
of these there's like massive space
between some of these roads and not all
the roads are properly labeled so if
it's something like that I would need
that trip odometer to tell me what I've
hit three point four miles because my if
I forgot to do that I would event I
would get to something like two miles
and go oh my god I haven't seen then I
must have passed it and turn around and
go back and I hadn't even gotten there
you like it's my sense of distance that
is the most screwed up if I'm trying to
find directions on my own I have so much
homework for him tomorrow I'm losing my
mind those live streams the only thing
keeping me sane right now oh man then it
breaks my heart to say that I really
need to need to wrap it up for the night
been learning more about my disability
cerebral palsy in the last few weeks and
it makes complete sense to me now it is
funny how when you kind of come to a
better understanding of some of these
things and it clicks a few things into
place
about yourself to you and like that
that's kind of nice when that happens
what part of endgame did you like I
liked pretty much the whole thing I
didn't I didn't have any complaints
about endgame I'm terrible with judging
just distance oven you and me you and me
both see the whole get comfortable thing
hitting because I moved so much during
high school and it just leaves me
feeling like I never got to establish
good friends so I just shut down back
that mean that that kind of thing can be
an impact a lot of time maps are not my
friend yeah maps like thank God for GPS
reliable GPS on the phone like it has
made my life so much easier thank God
wait this isn't gonna be a three-day
long livestream up to the weekend no no
it's not oh you know if I had if I had
the kind of time or if I thought I had
the you know the pull like some kind of
charity livestream you know just to keep
it going and raise money for something
I'd be up for that but like I also
wouldn't count on myself to organize it
so I don't know so that's something
something somebody find me a charity
livestream that I get like inject myself
into their you go off to feed the Fleur
kin and the Time Lord kitty yeah yeah I
got I got to close it out close it up
myself so thanks everybody
I hope you had a good Memorial Day
weekend I hope you have a good rest of
the week hope you see maybe a good movie
this weekend cuz there are there are
some ones coming out that should be good
I mentioned you know Rock'em and Liz and
I are gonna go try and see I've gotta
try and find the time to see Godzilla
cuz all right I really wanna like the
the last one wasn't great but like I'm
hopeful fingers crossed on this one and
if I get to that one I'll probably
actually put up a review on it
but thanks so much everybody thanks for
tuning in thanks for listening thanks
for the support those who chipped in
those who didn't thanks for sticking
around and if you watch if you subscribe
if you like
if you lurk whatever it is is going on
you're beautiful you're loved you are
valid
you are the council of geek